it's monsoon season in india after
beginning in may and building up over
june rains covered the entire country
over the weekend the monsoon is a
lifeline for farmers who depend on these
rains to grow their crops like rice but
very dry areas in the north and west
will be looking to the monsoon for
relief as well an intense heat wave this
year has brought drought to many parts
of rajasthan state here trains bringing
two million liters of water have become
the only reliable source of it
these 40 wagons all of them filled with
water are a lifeline for the state of
rajasthan
this dusted region often see
temperatures rise to about 45 degrees
celsius
but this year the heat wave arrived
earlier
three months of drought has left
thousands of inhabitants without water
look i open the tap and there's no water
at the moment we only get water once
every 10 days without water we can't do
anything
all i ask is for water to drink
twice a day local authorities fill up
the train with water from a lake nearby
and transport over 60 kilometers
as soon as the train arrives residents
flock to get their buckets filled
even though the water is not yet
drinkable it should be filtered by a
treatment plant before being
redistributed
yes this water is not filtered but what
can we do about it plastic bottles are
too expensive we can't afford to buy
them this problem has never been so
serious look at what we're facing today
prolonged drought has worsened the
situation here one of the driest regions
in india
artificial lakes have been empty since
last august
giving farmers a hard time
you see these little walls the water
used to rise up to here
everything was submerged
it has always been hot here but such a
lack of water i have never seen before
this lake was full
all the families had water this year we
have a real problem
for pawa and other residents the only
solution to their problems for now at
least is to train
we can speak now to dr aditi mukherjee
an expert on water issues who co-wrote
the chapter on water in this year's
report from the un's intergovernmental
panel on climate change she joins us
from kolkata in india welcome to dw news
asia
we've just been seeing the effects of
drought in india people are hoping for
relief with the monsoon rains which are
happening now how is that panning out
the monsoons while they were supposed to
be uh more or less normal they are they
are not being quite normal there has
been delays in various parts but is
still the very beginning of the monsoon
so there are still expectations and
predictions that the monsoon overall
will be normal for the continent as a
whole but even with normal monsoons what
happens is some regions gets more rain
and some regions get less so overall
it's been one month into the monsoon and
overall there have been deficiencies
with the prediction that those will be
uh caught up in the in the remaining two
months or so
okay so some areas are overall
overall are difficult
yeah please go ahead
so overall uh overall uh uh well a
difficult start to a monsoon let me put
it that way
okay so a difficult start today
difficult start to the monsoons as you
say some areas are expected to get
normal rains others less
india has also been experiencing
torrential flooding is this a case of
sometimes either too little water or too
much
yes just now as you speak there has been
um absolutely torrential rainfall and
and massive floods happening in the
northeast of india while there are you
know you're speaking of droughts in
rajasthan so
overall yes this is this happens this
has happened in the past but obviously
as we know that climate change is making
these patterns of too much rain and too
little rain uh
you know much more regular so what now
we are having is even though a monsoon
rainfall can be normal overall by normal
i mean total quantity of rain can be
similar but the entire rainfall pattern
can become very different so you may
have a huge rainfall even for a single
day and then a long stretches of dry
period and that has been one of the ways
in which climate change has been
affecting monsoonal rainfall by changing
the actual rainfall even
okay so very different patterns of
rainfall as a result of climate change i
i'd like to talk to you a little about a
little bit about some of the solutions
earlier this year you wrote in the
journal nature that limiting global
warming and i'm going to quote you here
requires carbon carbon emissions to
plummet immediately but too many carbon
removal of efforts overlook demands on
water could you explain what you mean by
that
yes so while we know that this is the
decade where we have to take huge amount
of mitigation action reduce carbon
dioxide emissions from pretty much all
our sectors we also know that if we
don't plan those very well there could
be negative impacts on water and land
and food by this i mean i can give you a
easy example of forestation or
forestation when you are putting in new
forest in regions that are already water
scarce what it can do is those forests
can actually use up young forest can use
up too much water in that space and
create local water scarcity the same
applies for measures such as growing
biofuel crops ah you know as a
substitute of fossil fuel and when you
are devoting land to growing crops that
are meant to be fuel instead of food
that can actually trigger things like
you know increase cost of food and
you know decrease access of food
particularly to the poor so that's what
we meant by the very we need to look at
the impacts of mitigation very carefully
having said that mitigation will remain
central we have to mitigate we have to
reduce co2 emissions but we have to
choose judiciously making sure that our
um our mitigation does not then you know
lead to other negative consequences in
waterland or food that was what i had
meant in that article you quoted
okay and if i understand you correctly
you're basically saying that water needs
to be put at the heart of of the
solutions going forward is water being
ignored and if so why
that's a good question i think in the
climate community because of the way
these treaties are framed baby the paris
rb the glasgow
the goal is carbon mitigation so
majority of the climate will actually
all these negotiations take around
carbon carbon per se
but i think water is um
i would not say water is completely
ignored but it's kind of invisible it's
not been as
as visible as say the need to reduce co2
and water is inherent in many things as
the example i was giving that reducing
co2 also has water implications so i
think it's up to the water community and
the climate community to come together
and tease out these water implications
both for mitigation but also the way
people are adapting to changing climate
so uh
so yes maybe um
there isn't we don't talk water enough
in our climate uh climate negotiations
and you're talking about about various
stakeholders coming together what should
be done in terms of better better
management and policy making
i think for me one of the important
things would be
to have space on the table on the
climate negotiation table both for the
water community at large because water
community and the climate community
historically have not always worked
closely together i think that needs to
change
for successful climate change mitigation
or adaptation
but and also overall what needs to
happen is that those who will be most
affected by climate change and those
communities are often the ones who may
not have necessarily emitted large
amounts of carbon dioxide historically
they also need a space and a voice in
the table i refer to indigenous
communities i refer to low-income
countries so um i mean that's already
there through your nfs triple c uh
processes but it's just their voices
needs to come out louder and have to be
taken more cognizants off in future uh
discussions and actions so two things
water needs to have a place and the
voices of those who have actually been
deeply affected by climate change have
to have a voice a voice that matters
it's been really great to get your
insights today that was water expert dr
dr aditi mukherjee we really thank you
for your time
as we've been hearing india's water
shortages are being worsened by climate
change but a dedicated group of women
being called india's water friends are
working to change that after years of
back-breaking work they're starting to
see some really promising results
away the rubble one stone at a time
these women are building a dam to bring
a scarce resource back to their village
water
they hope to finish the dam in time to
catch some of the monsoon rains
the volunteers are part of an initiative
called jal saheli which translates as
water friends
there's been a water problem for about a
decade we stand in line and wait for
hours to get water from the pump there
have been fights over water
fetching water has always been the
responsibility of women in rural india
but in the drought head region of
bundelkhand their job has been getting
harder and harder
many wells in the area have completely
run dry unable to irrigate their fields
farmers have had to give up their land
and find work in the city
decades ago water was a
community-managed resource now it's
administered by india's government
jal sahili is helping its volunteers
rediscover old water storage techniques
every month we hold a meeting
we discuss the drought-prone areas of
the region and find where we should stop
the water
so that monsoon water is not wasted
and their efforts are paying off the
work of the volunteers has transformed
life in many villages
and through an information campaign
they're spreading the word to other
communities
113 villages are water sufficient with
efforts from jal saheli
now people get water throughout the year
they get water for drinking irrigation
and for their animals
villages are prospering now that there's
access to water again that's the result
of our work
and their work is far from done with
roughly 600 million indians facing acute
water shortages daily the water friends
will carry on their efforts to make sure
that water remains a resource available
for all
you